be original in the same way that the
first one
what what people liked about that flip
that defy expectations
I'll go back several decades but uh
staying alive and Saturday Night Fever
and I know I'm really dating myself here
but both fantastic films Staying Alive
to me
um I'm sorry yeah Staying Alive was was
a little bit better in my sense than
than Saturday Night Fever just because I
enjoyed John Travolta's Journey staying
in this crummy Hotel he's this hungry
dancer he meets vanilla Hughes who's got
this upper hand and can help him but
there are strings attached it's just a
fantastic cast of characters and to me I
thought that the the storytelling was
was richer but again that's that's going
back several years it's not a franchise
I understand that some of the viewers
may not know that movie but I thought
that the storytelling was was way better
but I
yeah do you remember that yeah I
remember it and uh I wish I could forget
it